.
Kaum ein Verbrechen
bewegt die Öffentlichkeit mehr
als Mord an Kindern.
Das ist verständlich,
denn gerade Kinder sind
gegenüber Fremden besonders arglos
und erwachsenen Tätern
wehrlos ausgeliefert.
Die Kantonspolizei Aargau versucht,
zwei solche Mordfälle zu klären.
Es ist nicht auszuschliessen,
dass beide Kinder
Opfer
ein und desselben Täters wurden.
(TV) Der Entführer
wird wie folgt beschrieben:
40-50 Jahre alt.
1,75-1,80 m gross, schlank,
dunkle, nach hinten gekämmte Haare.
Der Mann trug eine braune
Wildlederjacke mit Revers.
Vermutlich ist der Mann
im Besitz eines Fahrzeugs,
in welchem
der Knabe transportiert wurde.
Etwas Schlimmeres
kann man nicht erleben.
Jedes Kapitalverbrechen
ist ein schweres Verbrechen,
aber wenn es Kinder betrifft,
ist es eine andere Dimension.
Alle paar Monate oder Jahre
verschwanden wieder neue Kinder.
Die Besonderheit dieser Mordserie
besteht darin,
dass zehn Jahre lang
nach einem Täter gesucht wurde,
obwohl man ihn eigentlich
hätte kennen sollen.
Er ist ein unberechenbarer
und gefährlicher Mensch.
Er erwürgte die Kinder -
mit seinen Händen!
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
(TV) Seit gestern Abend
wird in Hägendorf/SO
ein neunjähriges Mädchen vermisst.
(TV) Schon wieder
verschwand ein Kind spurlos.
(TV) Die Leiche des Kindes wurde
unweit des Elternhauses gefunden.
Sie war eigentlich schüchtern.
Sie war eine tolle ...
... Tochter.
Sie war das älteste unserer Kinder.
Wir haben schöne Erinnerungen
an Fabienne.
Sie war ein fröhliches Mädchen.
Ich denke oft, wie sie jetzt wäre.
Wäre sie verheiratet?
Hätte sie eine Familie?
Was hätte sie gelernt?
Sie hatte sicher
eine gewisse Vorahnung.
Sie wusste aber nicht, was passiert.
Man sieht hier einen Richterstuhl
mit einem Totenkopf.
Ich glaube,
dass jeder Mensch
eine Vorahnung hat, bevor er stirbt.
"Es ist bald so weit."
Natürlich bin ich der Täter.
Über den Tathergang
werde ich nie sprechen.
Es war zu schrecklich.
Ich bin für mich selbst ein Rätsel,
das ich nicht lösen kann.
Es war ein ganz normaler Samstag.
1989.
Ja.
Ich pflückte Holunderblüten.
Es war schön.
Fabienne war 14 Tage zuvor
aus den Ferien im Wallis
zurückgekommen.
Sie war beim Götti gewesen.
Sie freute sich die ganze Zeit
auf die Chilbi.
Ich sagte ihr, wir könnten morgen,
also am Sonntag, gehen.
Sie meinte, sie wolle jetzt gehen.
Die vielen Lichter gefielen ihr.
Dann gingen wir alle hin.
Ja ...
Das war das Letzte.
* Sanfte Musik *
* Lachen und Karussellmusik *
Mein Name ist Viktor Dammann
und ich bin seit 1980 ...
... Polizei- und Gerichts-
berichterstatter beim "Blick".
Am Anfang war nicht die Rede
vom "Fall Ferrari",
sondern
von vielen verschwundenen Kindern,
die z.T. nie gefunden wurden.
(Imhof) Wir wussten bereits,
dass Kinder getötet worden waren.
Aber wir dachten natürlich nicht,
dass es derselbe war,
der schon vier, fünf Menschen
getötet hatte.
Als die Kindermorde geschahen,
war ich selbst noch Kind.
Ich erinnere mich gut
an die Vermisstenanzeigen,
wenn ich durchs Dorf ging,
am Coop oder an der Polizei vorbei.
Fotos aus dem Familienalbum,
lachende Kindergesichter.
Ich selber war acht oder neun
und sah in die Gesichter
der acht-, neunjährigen
Mädchen und Jungen.
Ich konnte mir nicht vorstellen,
dass die einfach verschwunden waren.
Am 12. Mai 1980
verschwand Ruth S.,
zwölf Jahre alt, auf dem Heimweg.
Sie fuhr mit dem Velo durch Würenlos
und kam nie zu Hause an.
Das Tragische ist: Der Vater
fand die ermordete Tochter im Wald.
Ich spielte gerade Tennis,
als der Anruf kam,
dass im Wald in Würenlos
ein Mädchen gefunden wurde.
Das Waldstück war sehr dunkel.
Auf einem Teppich,
auf dem Waldboden,
lag ein totes Mädchen,
z.T. ausgezogen.
Die Atmosphäre,
die mich dort erwartete,
war sehr speziell, sehr unangenehm.
Man stellte fest,
dass sich der Täter möglicherweise
am Kind vergriffen hatte.
Auf der Leiche des Mädchens wurde
beim Gesäss ein Schamhaar gefunden.
Dieses Schamhaar
wurde damals jedoch nie
auf die DNA untersucht.
Aus technischen Gründen
und weil es einfach vergessen wurde.
Zu jenem Zeitpunkt
war das kein eindeutiger Beweis.
Es war ein Indiz,
weil ein Haar vorhanden war,
aber es war nicht möglich,
aufgrund der DNA im Haar
den Täter zu bestimmen.
Das Zweite war:
Das tote Mädchen
hatte auf der linken Brust
eine schlimme Bisswunde.
Als man den Leichnam fand,
stellte man über der Brustwarze
einen Bissabdruck fest.
Der wurde bei der Obduktion
sichergestellt und fotografiert.
Das war der erste Fall
dieser Mordserie der 80er-Jahre
und mit ein Grund,
weshalb die Ermittlungen und
Gerichtsfälle im Aargau stattfanden.
Nach dem ersten Fall
dachte noch niemand an eine Serie.
Leider wurden wir dann
eines Besseren belehrt.
Am 20. März 1982 wurde wieder
ein Mädchen verschleppt.
Die achtjährige Rebecca B.
Sie war nie
in der Schule in Gettnau angekommen.
Die Leiche
wurde im Kanton Bern aufgefunden.
Bis heute ungeklärt.
14. April 1983, Loredana M.,
sechs Jahre alt.
Sie wollte in Spreitenbach
Stroh fürs Meerschweinchen kaufen.
Sie wurde von einer Nachbarin
an der Bushaltestelle gesehen,
verschwand dann aber spurlos.
Ich war bei den Eltern,
es gab auch noch Mittagessen.
Es war eine italienische Familie.
Der Vater
fragte mich sozusagen beim Dessert,
ob ich glaube,
dass Loredana noch lebe.
Ich konnte natürlich nicht sagen,
dass ich davon überzeugt war,
dass sie tot war.
Ich sagte,
man dürfe die Hoffnung nie aufgeben.
Monate später fand man von ihr
nur noch das Skelett.
In Rümlang im Wald.
Die Sonderkommission Rebecca -
benannt
nach einem der toten Mädchen -
wurde ins Leben gerufen,
nachdem man festgestellt hatte ...
... dass der Täter
in verschiedenen Kantonen aktiv war.
Teils auch in mehreren Kantonen
im selben Fall.
Im Fall von Loredana
ist beispielsweise
der Ort der Entführung Aargau
und der Ort der Entdeckung Zürich.
Da wurde erkannt,
dass man zusammenarbeiten muss.
Darum wurde die Sonderkommission
gegründet.
Die Mitarbeitenden der Sonder-
kommission trafen sich regelmässig,
um die Erkenntnisse
über die einzelnen Fälle
in den verschiedenen Kantonen
auszutauschen.
In der Zeit,
in der in der Schweiz
verzweifelt
nach dem Täter gesucht wurde,
lebte er ein wenig wie ein Phantom.
Er hatte mal hier einen Job,
mal dort.
Er zog auch viel um.
Ihm selber war sehr bewusst,
dass er im einen oder anderen Fall
vermutlich verdächtigt wurde,
da er selbst einmal
ein ähnliches Delikt begangen hatte.
Er beschreibt das
in seinen Briefen auch.
Dass er sich davor fürchtete,
verdächtigt zu werden.
Offenbar bestand die Angst
aber nur auf seiner Seite.
Bei der Polizei galt er nicht sofort
als Hauptverdächtiger.
Ich fühlte mich stets
von der Polizei verfolgt
und glaubte, man würde mich
seit Jahren beschatten.
Dauernd hatte ich Angst,
das Unglück aus 1971
würde entdeckt werden.
Und ich begann,
immer mehr Alkohol zu trinken.
Die Ermittlungsmethoden,
die der Polizei in den 80er-Jahren
zur Verfügung standen,
waren bedeutend kleiner
und begrenzter,
als das heute der Fall ist.
Die DNA ist heute
bei allen schweren Straftaten
ein ganz zentrales Beweismittel.
Damals war das in der Schweiz
noch nicht bekannt.
Das ist vermutlich mit ein Grund,
weshalb in diesen Jahren
Straftaten
nicht aufgeklärt werden konnten,
während das heute möglich wäre.
27. Oktober 1983.
Beni E., Bajo Cesa genannt,
zehn Jahre alt,
wurde entführt und ermordet.
Seine Eltern
führten ein Leben als Fahrende.
Er hätte bei den Haushalten
Scheren und Messer abholen sollen,
damit der Vater
sie schärfen konnte.
Er kam aber nie nach Hause.
Man war hilflos.
Man konnte nicht verstehen,
dass es wieder
zu einem Fall gekommen war.
Man hoffte, dass die Taten endlich
ein Ende nehmen würden,
aber es ging Jahre.
Es war sehr belastend -
auch für die Reporter.
12. Mai 1984.
Peter R. verschwand auch
auf dem Weg zur Schule.
Er wurde nie gefunden.
Bis heute fehlt jede Spur.
* Musik aus dem Radio *
Mir fiel auf, dass alle Kinder
im gleichen Alter waren.
Sie verschwanden sehr oft
an einem Samstag.
An jedem Samstag
waren wir ein wenig besorgt.
Und wenn an einem Samstag
eine Vermisstenmeldung eines Kindes
verbreitet wurde,
klingelten alle Alarmglocken.
Es gab einige Verbrechen
im Zusammenhang mit einer Chilbi.
Der Rummel,
Dorffeste, Pfadfinderfeste.
Es ist erstaunlich,
dass an Orten mit so vielen Menschen
einfach jemand mit einem Kind
verschwinden konnte.
Bei diesen Verbrechen
wird ersichtlich,
dass sich ein Täter genau überlegt,
wie er sich einem Kind nähert.
Und das setzte er dann um.
Für den nächsten Fall sind
die Schweizer Behörden zuständig:
Die Kantonspolizei Aargau
bearbeitet einen Fall,
der in der Schweiz
grosses Aufsehen erregt hat.
Den Mord an Daniel,
einem siebenjährigen Schüler
aus Niederglatt.
Am 7. September 1985,
also vor knapp drei Wochen,
hatte der Knabe mit seinen Eltern
das Dorffest in Rümlang/ZH besucht.
Dort war Daniel
plötzlich verschwunden.
Du weisst,
wo das Raclette-Stübli ist, nicht?
Wir warten dort auf dich.
- Ja.
Bis dann!
(TV) Vermutlich wurde er
von einem Unbekannten entführt.
Drei Tage später,
am 10. September 1985,
wurde die Leiche des Kindes
in einem Maisfeld bei Riniken,
einem Ort bei Brugg
im Kanton Aargau, gefunden.
Nachdem ich
etwa 3 m2 geschnitten hatte,
machte ich die Entdeckung.
Der Junge lag in Seitenlage -
so, als ob er schlief.
Er lag dort oder kauerte eher.
Die Kinder wurden meist erwürgt
oder mit einem Gegenstand
erdrosselt.
Es ist furchtbar,
wenn man sich vorstellt,
wie die Kinder litten.
Diese Todesangst -
das ist unvorstellbar.
Es gibt Taten,
die fundamental bedrohlich sind,
weil es sich um Kinder handelt
oder an einem bestimmten Ort
zufällig irgendwelche Menschen
umgebracht werden können.
Das trifft den Kern des Sicherheits-
gefühls einer Gesellschaft.
Gerade, wenn es um Kinder geht.
Das hat eine Auswirkung
weit über die Taten hinaus.
Es schürt Angst,
Eltern fragen sich,
ob sie ihr Kind
allein rauslassen dürfen.
Solange ein Täter frei herumläuft
und der Fall ungeklärt bleibt,
wird das Sicherheitsgefühl
der Bevölkerung bedroht.
Es ist ähnlich wie bei Terrortaten:
Es terrorisiert die Gesellschaft,
da die Angst für viele Menschen
zu einem ständigen Begleiter wird.
Wir hatten Angst,
da immer wieder ein Kind verschwand.
Als Mädchen wurde mir beigebracht:
"Spricht dich ein fremder Mann an,
schreist du und läufst davon."
Unter Eltern
herrschte grosse Unsicherheit.
Sie hatten Angst,
die Kinder rauszulassen,
da sie fürchteten,
es könnte etwas passieren.
Die Eltern passten auf,
dass die Kinder nie allein waren
und immer ein Erwachsener
in der Nähe war.
In dieser Unruhe,
diesem Verfolgungswahn
floh ich oft in meine Kindheit.
Dort fand ich einigermassen
Trost und Ruhe.
Das ist wahrscheinlich
einer der bekanntesten Fälle.
Sie war fünf Jahre alt
und hatte auf dem Schulhof in Saxon
mit dem Velo Runden gedreht -
am Schluss blieb nur das Velo übrig.
Es war
ganz in der Nähe des Elternhauses.
(TV) Der Fall Oberson
macht europaweit Schlagzeilen.
Es geht
um die Schülerin Sarah Oberson.
Sie wurde bis heute nicht gefunden.
Man hat keine Ahnung,
was vorgefallen sein könnte.
* Düstere Musik *
Es herrscht ein grosses Bedürfnis,
sich ganz klar
davon zu distanzieren.
Das als etwas Krankes,
als Bestie, als Monster
aus dem normalen Lebensbereich
auszuschliessen.
Zu sagen, es sei etwas ganz anderes
und entsprechend zu kennzeichnen.
Meine Position ist immer,
das zu verstehen.
Da
helfen solche Begriffe nicht weiter.
Man muss akribisch untersuchen,
was das für eine Person ist
und was die Gründe sind.
Am 3. Mai 1986, Edith T.
Sie kam nie in der Schule
in Wolfikon an.
Bis heute weiss niemand,
was geschah.
Es gibt immer sehr viele,
die daran denken
und auch zeigen,
dass wir nicht allein sind,
dass sie mitfühlen ...
... und den Schmerz mit uns tragen.
Wir wussten, dass die Polizei
in den USA weiter war.
Darum versuchten wir,
davon zu profitieren.
Wir holten auch Profilkenner,
also Profiling-Experten
aus den USA in die Schweiz.
Aufgrund der Fotografien
der Tatorte versuchten sie,
ein Täterprofil zu erstellen.
Das war wertvoll.
Die amerikanischen Kollegen
bestätigten eigentlich,
was wir mit unseren einfacheren
Mitteln auch vermutet hatten.
Von den Amerikanern
lernten wir insbesondere
Tatorte zu lesen,
die Fotografien
und die Umstände der Verletzungen.
Auch die richtige Zeugenbefragung,
wenn es Zeugen gab.
Das brachte neue Perspektiven, aber
nicht den durchschlagenden Erfolg.
Schon wenige Tage danach
tauchte die bange Frage auf:
"Wer ist wohl das nächste Opfer?"
17. Oktober 1987.
Christian W., zehn Jahre alt,
verschwindet
an einer Jungscharfeier in Windisch.
(TV) Wieder ein Festplatz,
wieder ein Samstag.
(TV) In der Gemeinde Windisch,
nur wenige Kilometer vom
Leichenfundort in Riniken entfernt,
feiert eine Jungschar
ihr 50-jähriges Bestehen.
Der zehnjährige Christian
ist eines der rund 100 Mitglieder.
Er kam an diesem Tag
allein mit dem Zug
von Döttingen
ans Fest nach Windisch.
Ab 18 Uhr verlagert sich
das Geschehen in die Turnhalle.
Hier nehmen die Mitglieder -
z.T. mit Angehörigen und Bekannten -
ein gemeinsames Abendessen ein.
Gegen 19 Uhr verlässt der Schüler
unbemerkt die Dorfturnhalle.
Niemand weiss, warum.
Niemand weiss,
was sich gleich danach zutrug.
Während in der Turnhalle
das Fest auf vollen Touren läuft,
kommt es auf einer Landstrasse
zwischen Rüfenach und Riniken
zu einer bedeutsamen Beobachtung im
Zusammenhang mit dem Verschwinden.
Ein Mofafahrer
mit Rücklichtproblemen
sieht im Scheinwerferlicht
einen Mann
mit einem rund zehnjährigen Kind:
vermutlich Christian
mit seinem Mörder.
Am nächsten Tag fand eine Gruppe
Reiter im Wald seine Leiche.
* Düstere Musik *
Auch er wurde erdrosselt.
Seine Leiche wurde in der Nähe
des Fundorts von Daniel S. gefunden.
Spätestens da wurde klar,
dass wohl derselbe Täter
am Werk gewesen war.
Der Gedanke an das,
was in den letzten Jahren geschah,
ist unvorstellbar.
Ich muss verrückt gewesen sein,
besessen.
Noch kann ich mir
das nicht alles erklären.
(TV) Kaum ein Verbrechen
bewegt die Öffentlichkeit mehr
als Mord an Kindern.
Die Kantonspolizei Aargau versucht,
zwei solche Mordfälle zu klären,
die auffällige Parallelen aufweisen.
Es ist nicht auszuschliessen,
dass beide Kinder
Opfer ein und desselben Täters
wurden.
Die Teilnahme bei "Aktenzeichen XY"
war immer an die Bedingung geknüpft,
dass alle anderen Ermittlungs-
methoden schon ausgeschöpft waren.
Kommt man selber nicht weiter,
kann man zum Fernsehen gehen.
Nach dem zweiten Mord
stellte die Kantonspolizei Aarau
eine Reihe an Parallelen fest.
Für Hauptmann Urs Winzenried,
der jetzt im Studio ist,
ist dies ein bedeutender Faktor.
Das stimmt.
Aufgrund dieser Parallelen
ergeben sich verschiedene Fragen,
die mit einiger Wahrscheinlichkeit
in beiden Mordfällen
auf ein und dieselbe Person
als Täter hindeuten.
In der Hoffnung,
dass noch während der Sendung
erste Anrufe kommen,
war die Polizei parat.
Bei einer
Erfolg versprechenden Meldung
hätten sie dem sofort nachgehen
und nach dem Rechten sehen können.
Und so hätte der Fall vielleicht
gleich geklärt werden können.
Das war schon speziell.
Die Entführung von Daniel 1985
in Rümlang
wurde von mehreren Zeugen
beobachtet.
Der Entführer
wird wie folgt beschrieben:
40-50 Jahre alt.
1,75-1,80 m gross,
schlank,
dunkle nach hinten gekämmte Haare.
Der Mann trug eine braune
Wildlederjacke mit Revers,
Ärmel und Brustpartie aus Wolle.
In beiden Fällen
hinterliess der Täter
ähnliche Tatwerkzeuge,
mit denen er seine Opfer
zuvor erdrosselt hatte.
Im Fall Daniel
verwendete der Täter
diese goldfarbene Vorhangkordel
mit Quaste, ungefähr 1 m lang.
Im Fall Christian
benutzte er diesen braunen Gürtel
aus Nickiplüsch, der vermutlich
zu einem Bade- oder Morgenmantel,
allenfalls zu einem Hausdress
gehört.
Unsere Frage: Wer kann Angaben
zum Fehlen dieser Objekte machen?
Wir zeigten diese Objekte.
Gleichzeitig versuchten wir -
wie schon zuvor -,
diese Vorhangkordel und
den Bademantelgürtel zuzuordnen.
Das ist wieder ein Bespiel
für die Suche
nach der Stecknadel im Heuhaufen.
Es gibt unendlich
viele Vorhangkordeln.
Und jemand hätte sagen müssen:
"Ich kenne jemanden
mit solchen Vorhangkordeln,
bei dem jetzt
nur noch eine von beiden hängt."
Oder dass jemand einen Bademantel
ohne Gurt hatte.
Es bestanden
sehr kleine Erfolgschancen -
aber man versuchte es.
Hatte man das Gefühl,
dass es ernst war,
ging man den Hinweisen nach.
Es gab keine Sendung,
bei der keine Hinweise eingingen,
die man dann verfolgte.
Die Besonderheit dieser Mordserie
besteht darin,
dass zehn Jahre lang
nach einem Täter gesucht wurde,
obwohl man ihn eigentlich
hätte kennen sollen.
Der Täter hatte 1971
schon einmal gemordet.
Er hatte einen Jungen
von einem Festplatz entführt
und auf eine ähnliche Art
umgebracht.
Bei niemandem
klingelten die Alarmglocken -
ausser bei der Mutter des Opfers.
Sie hatte die Polizei kontaktiert,
um darauf hinzuweisen,
dass es derselbe Täter sein könnte,
doch lange geschah nichts.
Die interkantonale Zusammenarbeit
in den 80er-Jahren
funktionierte im Rahmen der
damaligen Möglichkeiten sehr gut.
Wir tauschten
regelmässig Informationen aus,
aber im Vergleich
zu heute war das sehr schwierig,
weil es keine so schnellen Mittel
wie Computer gab.
Man musste telefonieren,
sich zusammen hinsetzen.
Es gab keine
gesamtschweizerischen Datenbanken.
Aber im Rahmen des Möglichen funk-
tionierte die Zusammenarbeit gut.
Damals
gab es noch keinen Datenschutz.
Darum konnten wir sicher mehr
Informationen austauschen als heute.
Andererseits
geschah alles eher informell.
Die Polizisten kannten sich
und sprachen miteinander.
Da wurde aber nie
etwas aufgeschrieben.
Ich weiss nicht,
ob es
an der kantonalen Vielfalt lag ...
... dass Werner Ferrari
so lange in Freiheit bleiben konnte.
(TV) Ferrari ist vorbestraft:
Anfang der 1970er-Jahre
wurde er wegen des Mordes
an einem Jungen
zu zwölf Jahren Zuchthaus
verurteilt.
Mein Name ist Peter H.
Ich kenne Werner Ferrari
seit meiner Kindheit.
Mit neun, zehn Jahren
lernte ich ihn kennen,
weil er bei uns ein und aus ging.
Ich erinnere mich,
wie wir am Mittagstisch sassen
und Mutter sehr bedrückt war.
Wir wussten nicht, was los war.
Dann verkündete sie
aus heiterem Himmel,
dass Werner ein Mörder geworden sei.
Das war ein Hammer.
Das erschlug uns sehr.
Dann war es ruhig am Tisch.
Wir waren sehr betroffen
von dieser ...
... Tatsache.
Wir sahen ihn
nur noch als Gefangenen.
Wir sahen ihn in Arlesheim,
wo er in U-Haft war,
weil wir ihn besuchten.
Ich ging ihn
mit meinem Vater besuchen.
Werner Ferrari
war ein Freund von uns.
Er war ein Freund der Familie.
Und so ...
... sahen wir es
als selbstverständlich an ...
... ihn zu besuchen.
1979 wurde er entlassen.
Er kam ja drei oder vier Jahre
früher raus.
Ursprünglich waren es ja
zwölf Jahre Haft gewesen.
Er kam früher raus,
was wir auch wussten.
Dann nahmen wir Kontakt zu ihm auf.
Wir luden ihn
zum Spaghetti-Essen ein.
Er erschien jedoch nicht.
1980 erfuhren wir in der Presse
vom ersten Mordfall an Ruth S.
Ich sagte zu meiner Frau,
dass Werner Ferrari
nun sicher wieder observiert würde.
Ich erklärte ihr das.
Bei einem solchen Vorfall,
wird man als Erster
nach einem Alibi gefragt.
Als in der Presse nichts stand,
war ich schon beinahe beruhigt.
Ich schrieb ihm das nicht zu.
Jeder Kanton
verfügte über seine Daten.
Wollte man auf Daten anderer Kantone
zugreifen,
musste man jedes Mal
ein Gesuch stellen.
Das erschwerte die Arbeit
natürlich sehr.
Einen Mann,
der schon einmal einen Mord
an einem Jungen begangen hatte,
muss man doch anschauen.
Mit zunehmender Dauer
dieser Kindstötungen ...
... bekam eine sog. schwarze Liste
eine Bedeutung.
Die schwarze Liste
enthielt Namen von Straftätern,
die im Zusammenhang
mit schweren Sexualdelikten,
aber auch Tötungsdelikten
in der Schweiz eine Rolle spielten.
Damit versuchte man,
den Täterkreis etwas einzugrenzen.
Aber es war natürlich kein Indiz,
auf einer schwarzen Liste zu stehen.
Und diese Liste
war auch relativ lang.
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
Vielleicht ist die Tatsache,
dass Ferrari in der halben Schweiz
getötet hat, ein wichtiger Punkt.
Vielleicht ...
... dachte man
bei der einen Polizei,
eine andere
sollte sich darum kümmern -
und umgekehrt.
Wie es dazu kam,
dass er nicht vorher
richtig überprüft wurde,
weiss ich nicht.
1987 besuchte ihn die Polizei.
Er wohnte damals in Adelboden.
Er arbeitete bei den Mineralquellen.
Die Polizei
tauchte an seinem Arbeitsplatz auf -
jedoch wegen eines Finanzdelikts -
und befragte ihn dort.
Das war sein Horrorszenario.
Er hatte immer Angst, wegen
der Morde verdächtigt zu werden,
da er ja schon einmal
ein Kind umgebracht hatte.
Er machte sogar eine Bemerkung,
dass er sich verdächtigt fühle.
Aber auch dann
geschah nichts in diese Richtung.
Wie kommt es, dass Ferrari,
nachdem er 1970 schon einmal
ein Kind umgebracht hatte,
wieder auf freiem Fuss war?
Das stiess mir sauer auf.
Dass man einen Sexualstraftäter
dieses Kalibers freiliess.
Wer kann sagen,
dass sich ein Mensch
nach nur einer Tat niemals bessert?
Damals war Werner Ferrari
noch relativ jung.
Es wird kaum von Anfang an
über jemanden gesagt,
dass man ihn nie wieder
unter die Menschen lassen kann.
Das entspricht nicht
unserem Menschenbild.
Selbst meinem nicht.
Das würde man heute
ganz anders sehen.
Der Grund für die Haft
ist ein Tötungsdelikt.
Wir wollen das verstehen.
Wie kam es dazu?
Wie ist das Risiko in Zukunft?
Was muss man beobachten?
Das wäre heute
eine ganz andere Situation.
Im Fall Ferrari zeigt sich,
dass es damals
noch keine Sensibilität dafür gab.
Man hatte die Sicht
auf die Gefährlichkeit noch nicht
und führte diesbezüglich
keine präzise Beurteilung durch,
um entsprechende Massnahmen
zu ergreifen.
Das gab es damals nicht.
Als die Mordserie begann,
wurde sein Vormund befragt.
Er war also schon auf dem Radar.
Der Vormund lobte ihn jedoch
in den höchsten Tönen
und meinte,
er habe sich total gebessert.
Er sprach ihn eigentlich
schon vom Verdacht frei.
Dass diese Serie von Kindermorden
so lange
nicht aufgeklärt werden konnte,
ist sicher nicht Schuld der Polizei.
Der Täter hatte lange keinen
entscheidenden Fehler begangen.
Dass der Chef der Kripo meinte,
um den Täter zu erwischen,
müsse vielleicht
ein weiterer Mord geschehen ...
Sie hatten offensichtlich niemanden.
Sie hatten keine Spur -
oder sahen sie nicht.
Sie war wahrscheinlich schon da,
wurde aber nicht gesehen.
Der Mord war unnötig,
er hätte verhindert werden können,
wenn die Polizei
besser zusammengearbeitet hätte
und man anders auf Hinweise
reagiert hätte.
Das ist extrem brutal
für Fabiennes Eltern und Angehörige.
Es ist nicht leicht zu verkraften,
wenn man weiss,
dass das Kind noch leben würde,
wenn anders und besser
gearbeitet worden wäre.
In diesen neun Jahren taten wir
in jedem Fall, in jedem Kanton,
das Menschenmögliche.
Trotzdem kamen wir nicht zum Erfolg.
Vielleicht führte das
zu einer gewissen Hilflosigkeit,
weil wir unser Ziel
einfach nicht erreichten.
Das war belastend.
Das war vielleicht mit ein Grund
für diese Aussagen in der Zeitung.
(Imhof) An diesem Samstag
waren wir erst noch in der Kirche.
Danach gingen wir zur Chilbi
und assen etwas.
Dann gingen wir zu den Putschautos.
Fabienne wollte dann mit Eliane
auf die andere Seite gehen.
Und wir sagten: "Ja, geht."
Für ihn
war es wohl am besten, zu schauen,
wann ein Kind
von der Chilbi wegging.
Dann ging er ihm nach.
Er lauerte - wie ein Jäger.
* Bedrohliche Musik *
Dann ...
... ging er mit Fabienne
und einem anderen Mädchen
durch das Dorf
und die Eigasse entlang.
In einer Seitengasse
stellte er das andere Mädchen ab
und sagte ihm, es solle warten,
er würde wiederkommen.
In dieser Zeit ging er mit Fabienne
an unserem Haus vorbei
den Lindenweg entlang.
Dorthin, wo er sie umbrachte,
ermordete und ...
... vergewaltigte.
(Ferrari)
Als ich Fabiennes Weinen vernahm,
erinnerte ich mich an mein Delikt
vor 18 Jahren
und ich verlor die Nerven.
Offensichtlich
bemerkte Fabienne meine Veränderung
und begann noch heftiger zu weinen.
(Imhof) Das zweite Mädchen,
das er unten in einer Seitengasse
abgestellt hatte,
war dort stehen geblieben.
Irgendwann begann es zu weinen.
Zwei Paare kamen vorbei
und fragten, was los sei.
Da meinte es, ein Mann habe es ab-
gestellt und ihm befohlen zu warten.
Dann fragten sie, wo es denn wohne.
Die beiden Paare brachten
das kleine Mädchen dann nach Hause
nach Hägendorf.
Es war schätzungsweise ...
... 22.30 Uhr.
- Nein, ca. 21.30 Uhr, 21.45 Uhr.
Und Fabienne
wurde ja gemäss Analyse ...
... zwischen 21.50 und 21.55 Uhr
ermordet.
(Ferrari) Während ich mich erhob,
begann das Mädchen laut zu schreien,
weshalb ich ihm den Mund zuhielt.
Als auch das nichts brachte,
muss mein Hass durchgebrochen sein,
sodass ich seinen Hals zudrückte,
bis es tot war.
"Da kam zufällig jemand."
"Da passierte etwas."
"Da ging etwas schief."
"Plötzlich werde ich wütend."
"Und dann ist das Kind tot."
Es hat etwas sehr Fragmentiertes,
Zufälliges,
das sich aus dem Moment heraus
entwickelt.
Das ist vollkommen unplausibel.
Es ist viel plausibler, dass er sich
auch unabhängig von den Taten
sehr stark mit den Szenarien
beschäftigte.
Ob es aus Wut geschieht
oder ganz banal
um Zeugen zu beseitigen -
aus welchem Motiv auch immer:
Es ist naheliegend,
dass in einem Szenario,
in dem er kontrolliert,
in dem er manipuliert,
in dem er die volle Kontrolle
über das Kind hat,
diese Kontrolle sich fast nahtlos
in die Tötung des Kindes umsetzt.
Ich hatte einen guten Freund,
der meinte,
dass wir uns das ansehen sollten.
So gingen wir den Lindenweg entlang.
Damals war das ganze Gebiet
noch nicht überbaut.
Im August
gibt es in der Nacht Feuchtigkeit.
Das Gras ist nass.
Vom Lindenweg aus
sah man zwei Spuren in der Wiese.
Wo zwei Personen
durchgegangen waren.
Wir gingen ein Stück.
Dann meinten wir:
"Lass uns zurückgehen,
das bringt nichts."
Wenn wir den Spuren noch
einige Minuten gefolgt wären ...
... hätten wir Fabienne
selber gefunden.
Es war schwierig -
das weiss ich noch.
Es war schwierig, dass ...
... man es
einfach nicht genau wusste.
Das war schwierig.
Am Sonntagnachmittag
um ca. 13.30 Uhr
kam der Gemeindepräsident zu uns
und sagte,
man habe Fabienne gefunden -
und sie seit tot.
Im Fall Fabienne konnte eine
Augenzeugin den Täter beschreiben.
Sie konnte ein Bild zeichnen lassen,
wie er aussah.
Aufgrund dessen kam es
zu Hinweisen aus der Bevölkerung.
Darum klopfte die Polizei bei ihm.
Herr Ferrari?
Er war jedoch nicht zu Hause
und sie gingen wieder.
Dann geschah etwas,
das im Nachhinein alle überraschte:
Ist hier die Kantonspolizei?
Mein Name ist Werner Ferrari,
ich erfuhr eben von einer Nachbarin,
dass die Polizei
nach mir gefragt hatte.
Ich bin jetzt zu Hause,
aber ich sage Ihnen gleich:
Wegen der Sache in Hägendorf
brauchen Sie nicht kommen.
Damit habe ich nichts zu tun.
Damit verriet er sich selbst.
Er war zwar auf dem Radar gewesen,
man hatte ihn aber ignoriert.
Durch den Anruf verriet er sich.
* Spannungsgeladene Musik,
Türklingel *
Es war ein grosser Moment,
als der Kindermörder
endlich gefasst wurde.
Das war eine grosse Erleichterung
für die Bevölkerung.
Als der Täter
von der Kantonspolizei Solothurn
verhaftet werden konnte,
war die Erleichterung
bei der ganzen Polizei der Schweiz
sehr gross.
Bei mir persönlich natürlich auch.
Der Kanton Aargau war von
den Tötungen ja massiv betroffen.
Als im Verlauf der Wochen
der polizeiliche Sachbearbeiter
in Solothurn
ein Geständnis
nach dem anderen erfassen konnten,
wurde die Erleichterung
immer grösser.
Sowie die Überzeugung,
dass der richtige Täter
gefasst worden war.
* Emotionale Musik *
Schaut man heute auf die Fälle
zurück und sieht,
dass sie immer
nach dem gleichen Muster geschahen,
Werner Ferrari
sogar auf einer Liste stand,
man bei ihm anklopfte
und ihn wieder vergass,
als er nicht zu Hause war ...
Ich bin überzeugt: Heute würde
eine Serie nicht so lange dauern.
Und dass der letzte Mord
hätte verhindert werden können.
Der letzte Fall ...
... war zum Glück der letzte.
Andererseits
war das wieder ein Fall zu viel.
Bei der Polizei stellte man sich
natürlich die Frage,
ob man hätte verhindern können, dass
noch ein Kind hatte sterben müssen.
Diese Frage stellte man sich, ja.
(TV) Im Zusammenhang mit dem Mord
in Hägendorf
hat die Kantonspolizei Solothurn
einen Mann festgenommen.
(TV) Der Verdächtige
ist seit Donnerstag in Gewahrsam.
(TV) Der Mörder der neunjährigen
Fabienne Imhof ist geständig.
Jemand von der Kripo kam vorbei.
Er teilte uns mit ...
... dass ein Geständnis
abgelegt worden war.
Wie war das für Sie?
Im Moment ...
- ... eine Erleichterung.
Ja, es war eine Erleichterung.
Man wusste, wer es getan hatte.
Man wusste,
dass Fabienne noch da ist.
Sie lebt nicht mehr,
aber wir haben sie noch.
Es gibt viele Fälle in der Schweiz,
in denen die Eltern
nach 30, 40, 50 Jahren nicht wissen,
wo das eigene Kind ist.
Das ist etwas vom Schlimmsten
überhaupt.
* Bedrohliche Musik *
Die Geständnisse
kamen nicht alle auf einmal,
sondern in Etappen,
mit teils Wochen dazwischen.
Aber nach jedem Geständnis wurde
die Erleichterung noch grösser,
dass man den Täter erwischt hatte.
Anders als Laien denken,
sind Geständnisse kein Beweismittel
für sich par excellence.
Sondern sie müssen
mit Vorsicht beurteilt werden.
Es gibt taktische Geständnisse.
Es gibt falsche Geständnisse.
Aus diesem Grund
darf man das Geständnis
als Beweismittel nicht überbewerten.
Da er es zugab,
dachte man, dass nun der Prozess
stattfinden konnte.
Aber dem war dann nicht so.
Ich werde nicht bereit sein,
ein mir zur Last gelegtes Delikt
einzugestehen,
von dem ich überzeugt bin,
dass ich es niemals begangen habe.
Es war für ihn sicher
ein schwieriger Fall.
Mal sagte er dies,
dann wieder etwas anderes.
(Urbaniok) Das war - zumindest
teilweise - eine bewusste Strategie.
Lese ich die Einvernahmen,
wird mir das ganz klar.
Ein Hauptziel der Einvernahmen
ist nicht, etwas zu sagen,
sondern etwas Bestimmtes
nicht zu sagen.
"Geliebte Eltern."
"Im Kampf gegen das Unfassbare
fällt es mir schwer,
euch einige Zeilen
zukommen zu lassen."
"Ungewollt habe ich euch
grosses Leid zugefügt."
Er schrieb an mich.
Quasi eine Entschuldigung.
Aber wir haben den Brief nicht mehr.
"Es gibt keine Möglichkeit, das
Schreckliche ungeschehen zu machen."
"Aber aufrichtig darf ich sagen:
Es tut mir leid."
"Mutter, verzeih mir."
"Fabienne - was ich tat,
das wollte ich nie."
Wir konnten ihm beide vergeben.
Das schrieben wir auch öffentlich:
"Wir verzeihen dir."
"Aber wir
verstehen deine Tat nicht."
Das schrieben wir.
Das gab einen Aufruhr
in der Gesellschaft.
Das ist auch verständlich, aber ...
... hasse ich einen Hund,
beisst er immer wieder.
Sie sagen, dass ich einen Menschen -
ein Kind - getötet haben soll.
In meiner Erinnerung
sind alle vier noch am Leben.
Bei einer Serie
liegt die Zuständigkeit
in der Schweiz dort,
wo die erste Tat stattfand.
Im Kanton Aargau
waren wir uns bewusst,
dass das ganze Verfahren
in den Aargau kommen würde,
sollten wir für den ersten Fall
diesen Täter verdächtigen.
Speziell ist, dass er diese Tat
von Anfang an abstritt.
(Dammann)
Das ist ein prestigeträchtiger Fall.
Man muss sich sogar fragen,
ob Werner Ferrari
im Fall Ruth S. angeklagt wurde,
da man den Prozess unbedingt
im Aargau durchführen wollte.
(Kuhn) Speziell war,
dass man
sehr, sehr umfangreiche Akten hatte
mit Ermittlungsberichten
von verschiedenen Polizeistellen.
Es gab viele begangene Delikte.
Es gab ...
... Taten, bei denen die Opfer
sofort gefunden werden konnten,
andere, bei denen die Opfer
schon verwest oder zerfallen waren.
Und es gab Taten,
bei denen man nur das Skelett fand.
* Bedrohliche Musik *
Warum zeigt mir Herr P. den Ort,
wo dieser Junge liegen soll?
Er meinte, ich sei der Täter,
wisse es aber nicht mehr.
Vier Fälle - glaube ich -
gab er ja zu.
Das waren eigentlich
alles gleiche Fälle.
Da sah man, dass sein Ziel war,
die gleichartigen Fälle zuzugeben,
während er die anderen abstritt.
Die Indizien der ungeklärten Ver-
brechen sind sehr unterschiedlich.
Im Fall Würenlos haben wir
eine Reihe starker Indizien,
die für Ferrari als Täter sprechen.
In anderen Fällen
ist die Indizienlage weniger sicher.
Fast sechs Jahre
nach seiner Festnahme
muss sich Werner Ferrari
vor Gericht verantworten.
Laut Anklage soll er fünf Kinder
auf ähnliche Weise umgebracht haben:
Er gewann das Vertrauen der Kinder
und lockte sie
an einen einsamen Ort.
Dort bedrängte er sie sexuell.
Wehrten sie sich, brachte er sie um.
Mein Name ist Guido Näf.
Ich führte damals den Strafprozess
gegen Werner Ferrari.
Bei grossen Straffällen
sprachen wir Präsidenten uns
in der Regel untereinander ab,
wer den Fall
übernehmen will oder kann.
Dieser Fall war speziell,
da es um Kindstötungen ging.
Wir Präsidenten
besprachen das untereinander.
Meine beiden Kollegen
hatten beide Kinder in diesem Alter.
Ich habe keine Kinder.
So kamen wir zum Schluss,
dass ich den Fall übernehme.
Ende 1994 stand Werner Ferrari
endlich vor Gericht.
Das wurde durch die Medien
sehr breit abgedeckt.
Es war ein grosser Moment.
(Überlappende Nachrichten)
In Baden steht heute ...
Heute beginnt der Prozess gegen
den mutmasslichen Kindermörder.
... direttamente dal carcere ...
... Kinder entführt
und getötet haben.
Die Sicherheitsdispositive,
die wir aufgeboten hatten,
die anwesenden Medien ...
Es war voll,
da waren etwa 35 Medienleute.
Da spürte man schon,
dass sehr viel Sensationslust
dabei war.
(TV) Manche Besucher
sprachen sich am Rande des Prozesses
gegen den mutmasslichen Kindermörder
gar für die Wiedereinführung
der Todesstrafe aus.
Es gab Stimmen,
die die Todesstrafe forderten,
die meinten, dass so jemand
kein Recht mehr habe zu leben,
man ihn umbringen müsse.
Ich bin gegen die Todesstrafe.
Ich kriegte fünf Anrufe von Leuten,
die anprangerten,
dass ich nicht
für die Todesstrafe war.
Ich bin noch heute dagegen.
Ich erfuhr,
dass sein Pflichtverteidiger
ein 81-jähriger Anwalt
aus Zürich war.
Er war eigentlich Scheidungsanwalt.
Und es war schon seltsam,
als der zu mir sagte,
dass es eigentlich klar sei, was man
mit Herrn Ferrari tun sollte:
Für ihn wäre nur die Todesstrafe
richtig gewesen.
Schwierig,
wenn ein Pflichtverteidiger so
über seinen Mandanten spricht.
Er erwürgte die Kinder -
mit seinen Händen!
Oder mit einer Vorhangschnur.
Oder mit einem Bademantelgürtel.
Aber er erwürgte sie, bis sie ...
... sich nicht mehr bewegten.
Das ist verrückt.
Und dass es einen schüttelt,
ist ja normal.
Ich bin auch nur ein Mensch.
Man muss diese Emotionen
halt im Griff haben.
Aber wenn es niemand sieht,
darf es einen schütteln.
Mein Ziel ist,
dass der Angeklagte Ferrari ...
... nicht mehr
in die Freiheit entlassen wird.
Wie schaffen Sie das?
Ich stelle einen Antrag
auf eine lebenslange Zuchthausstrafe
verbunden mit vollzugsbegleitender
psychotherapeutischer Behandlung.
Und hoffe, dass ihm nie eine
günstige Prognose gestellt wird,
dank der er bedingt auf Probezeit in
die Freiheit entlassen werden kann.
Man hoffte einfach,
dass ein richtiges Urteil
gefällt wird.
Dass er verurteil wird.
Dass er von der Gesellschaft
getrennt wird.
Das ist das Wichtigste.
Er wurde hereingeführt.
Und ich sah ihn so,
wie ich Sie jetzt sehe.
* Düstere Musik *
Werner Ferrari
war eigentlich ein Nichts.
Ein Mensch, den man eigentlich
immer und überall übersieht.
Er ...
... war ein schlaksiger Mann.
Nicht jemand,
von dem man sich fürchtete.
Ich hätte keine Angst gehabt.
Er war kein Monster.
In solchen Fällen
ist es ja immer so,
dass man Nachbarn und Bekannte fragt
und die meisten erstaunt meinen,
der habe immer gegrüsst
und war freundlich.
Sie können sich das
gar nicht vorstellen.
Im Wettinger Rathaus,
wo das Verfahren
aus Platzgründen stattfindet,
begann alles wie erwartet.
Gerichtspräsident Näf
wies darauf hin,
dass er keinen Schauprozess,
sondern ein faires Verfahren wolle.
In der Regel wird eine Verhandlung
damit eröffnet,
dass man den Beschuldigten
zu seinen persönlichen Verhältnissen
befragt.
Danach
geht man auf die Anklagepunkte ein.
Als Guido Näf auf
die Tötungsdelikte zu sprechen kam,
änderte sich das Bild:
Ferrari widerrief seine Geständnisse
und behauptete,
er habe die Aussagen
aufgrund von Informationen
von Untersuchungsbeamten
und Medien gemacht.
Plötzlich!
Nachdem er es gestanden hatte.
Dann sagte er, das Geständnis
sei Erpressung gewesen.
Durch die Ermittlungsbeamten
und Polizisten.
Er war so davon überzeugt,
dass er es nicht getan hatte.
Er hatte es offenbar
so stark verdrängt,
dass er es gar nicht bereuen konnte.
Er sagte ja auch,
man müsse es wissen,
wenn man so etwas getan hat,
er wisse es aber nicht.
Also habe er es nicht getan.
Eigentlich sollte es
ein reibungsloser Prozess werden -
glatt und rasch durchzuziehen -,
doch der Angeklagte macht nicht mit.
Werner Ferrari, der als mut-
masslicher Mörder von fünf Kindern
im aargauischen Wettingen
vor Gericht steht,
hat seine Geständnisse, auf denen
der Prozess aufbaut, widerrufen.
Dann platzte der Prozess.
Er zog alle Geständnisse zurück.
Er hatte
einen sehr ungeeigneten Verteidiger,
der gar kein Strafrechtler war.
Der Verteidiger warf alles hin
und es musste ein neues Verfahren
eingeleitet werden.
Nachdem er das Mandat niederlegte,
mussten wir die Verhandlung
abbrechen.
Er hatte ja
keine angemessene Verteidigung mehr.
Der Staatsanwalt rechnet damit,
dass Ferrari im günstigsten Fall
in drei Monaten
wieder vor Gericht stehen wird.
Als Beobachterin
erhält man schon den Eindruck,
dass man es sich zu einfach machte,
da man sich zu sicher war.
Das war schon ein Schockmoment.
Auch für die Angehörigen
ist es sehr schwierig,
wenn man denkt,
der Täter würde verurteilt,
doch dieser zieht eine
solche Show ab und alles platzt.
Für das Gericht
wird der Fall schwieriger.
Es muss sich nun
auf Indizien abstützen.
Wenn ich mich richtig erinnere,
war die Strategie,
eine Erklärung dafür zu finden,
warum Herr Ferrari
die Geständnisse widerrufen hatte.
Er hatte ja oft geltend gemacht,
dass er beeinflusst worden sei,
dass er bedrängt worden sei,
ihm für Geständnisse Versprechungen
gemacht worden seien usw.
Er belastete eigentlich
die ermittelnden Beamten,
dass sie ihn beeinflusst hätten,
unter Drogen gesetzt
und weiss ich was.
(TV)
Schwierige Aufgabe für die Richter:
Sollen sie
den Geständnissen glauben?
Hinweise
könnten die Psychiater geben.
Mario Etzensberger
schilderte Ferrari als schizoid,
als Mann mit tiefer Kontaktstörung
zu sich und der Umwelt.
Ferrari
soll unter seinen Taten leiden
und versuche, sie zu verdrängen
und ungeschehen zu machen.
Es ist durchaus möglich,
dass jemand Geständnisse ablegt,
obwohl er nichts getan hat.
Das gibt es.
Nur würde das nicht
zu seiner Erzählart
und zum vorhandenen Kontext passen.
Nur weil es nicht passt,
heisst es aber nicht,
dass es nicht so war.
Mein Eindruck war,
dass das Erzählte authentisch ist.
Ich staunte, als er es widerrief.
Ich dachte nicht:
"Ah, jetzt widerruft er also."
Die Möglichkeit, dass es sich
um falsche Äusserungen handelt,
besteht durchaus,
ich würde sie jedoch
als relativ klein betrachten.
Ich frage mich:
Gibt es eine Möglichkeit,
das Geschehene
ungeschehen zu machen?
Jemand in mir antwortet:
"Nein, die gibt es nicht."
(Überlappende Nachrichten)
Was geht vor in Werner Ferrari,
der sich für Mord in fünf Fällen
verantworten muss?
Werner Ferrari a 49 ans,
originaire de Bâle,
il comparaît pour la deuxième fois
devant le tribunal de Baden.
Ferrari arriva in tribunale ...
Das halbe Leben hat Ferrari
hinter Gittern verbracht.
Ob er für immer dort bleibt,
entscheidet das Gericht.
Wichtigste Person heute:
Pflichtverteidiger
Martin Ramisberger.
Er übernahm erst vor sechs Monate
die Verteidigung von Ferrari.
Würden wir als Anwälte
einfach ein Mandat ablehnen ...
In der Justiz gibt es ja
eine obligatorische Verteidigung.
Ohne Verteidiger kein Urteil.
Ohne könnte man
den Täter einer Tötung - generell,
ich spreche nicht von diesem Fall -
gar nicht verurteilen.
Da der Angeklagte
bis zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt
den Widerruf seiner Geständnisse
aufrechterhält,
bleibt mir als Verteidiger
nichts anderes übrig,
als auf Freispruch zu plädieren.
Ich habe die Anträge
vom Dezember beibehalten,
da sich die Situation
aufgrund der Beweislage
nicht verändert hat.
Ich habe genügend Beweise.
Ich kann die Taten
auch ohne Beweise nachweisen.
Die Anklageschrift war ...
... wie man sie damals machte.
Sie war vorwerfend.
Sie enthielt Unterstellungen.
Sie schildert eine Geschichte,
die sich nicht anzweifeln lässt.
Das war immer das Wichtigste:
Eine Anklage
durfte man nicht zerreissen können.
Und die konnte man nicht zerreissen.
Und es waren gute Leute dort.
Bei konkreten Anschuldigungen
meinte er immer,
das stimme nicht,
das habe er nie gesagt.
Ich erinnere mich,
dass es eskalierte.
Ich konfrontierte ihn
mit Aussagen von ihm.
Dann fragte er,
wann er das gesagt haben soll.
Also bat ich ihn
nach vorn zum Richtertisch
und zeigte ihm
die unterschriebene Einvernahme.
Dann rastete er beinahe aus
und meinte, das stimme nicht,
das sei alles gelogen.
Dann wurde es etwas heikel.
Heute wurde Ferrari erstmals laut.
Als der Gerichtspräsident
die Misshandlungen schilderte,
rief Ferrari:
"Schweinerei, das ist gelogen!"
"Ihr werdet büssen!"
Ferrari ist noch im Gerichtsgebäude.
Ein Arzt musste ihm
eine Beruhigungsspritze geben.
Heute Morgen vor dem Rathaus:
Die Öffentlichkeit zeigte
grosses Interesse am Prozess.
Heute erwartete man das Urteil.
Dann erschien er - von der Polizei
schwer überwacht oder geschützt -
auf dem ihm bekannten Weg
zur Urteilsverkündung.
Ich erinnere mich, wie es mir
an der Urteilseröffnung ...
... in einem Moment kurz ...
... die Stimme verschlug.
Das war, als ich am Anfang
kurz zusammenfasste,
worum es im Prozess ging:
um die Tötung von fünf Kindern.
Dann verlas ich noch einmal
die Namen der fünf Kinder.
Das war der Moment,
als es mich kurz schüttelte.
Man hat es wohl nicht bemerkt,
aber ich erinnere mich daran.
Dass ich dort emotional ...
... betroffen war.
Ein aufwühlender Prozess
ist zu Ende:
Ferrari
wurde vom Bezirksgericht Baden
für schuldig befunden,
fünf Kinder ermordet zu haben.
Für die Richter/-innen
ist es erwiesen:
Werner Ferrari brachte zwischen 1980
und 1989 diese fünf Kinder um.
Das Gericht befand die zurück-
gezogenen Geständnisse als gültig
und verurteilte ihn zur Höchst-
strafe: lebenslanges Zuchthaus.
Das brachte nichts.
Fabienne ist tot.
Ein solches Urteil
ist überhaupt keine Hilfe.
Es ist höchstens ...
... eine Genugtuung,
da man weiss,
dass er bestraft wurde.
Aber es löst das Problem nicht.
Es war ein einstimmiges Urteil.
In diesem Moment
waren wir überzeugt,
dass das Urteil richtig war.
Und dass es gerecht war.
Es war das Maximum,
das man damals ...
... als Strafe aussprechen konnte.
Die Verwahrung kam erst später.
Darüber stimmten wir später ab.
Mir ist klar,
dass ich der Täter bin.
Nur: Ich kann es noch nicht glauben.
Peter Holenstein
steht seit sechs Jahren
in regelmässigem Kontakt
zum mehrfachen Kindsmörder.
Werner Ferrari sei mittlerweile
wie ein Bruder geworden.
In seinem neuen Buch
hält er die Begegnungen fest.
Ausschlaggebend,
weshalb ich auf das Thema kam,
war der Prozess 1995 -
der zweite Prozess.
Nachdem er beim ersten
die Geständnisse widerrufen hatte,
stellten sich mir viele Fragen.
Z.B. wie es kommt,
dass jemand
nach fünf Jahren Untersuchungshaft
plötzlich die Geständnisse
zurückzieht.
Warum es neun Jahre
bis zur Verhaftung dauerte.
Was ich nicht wusste und ich erst
durch Holensteins Buch lernte, war,
dass es eigentlich
eine Mordserie auf Ansage war.
Vor den Tötungsdelikten
war Werner Ferrari mit ca. 20
wegen kleinerer Delikte
in der Psychiatrie gewesen.
Es gab ein erstes psychiatrisches
Gutachten,
in dem ihm bereits Pädophilie
nachgewiesen worden war.
Der Psychiater hatte gemeint,
es sei nicht auszuschliessen,
dass er später ein pädophiles
Sexualdelikt begehen würde.
Als ich das las, schüttelte es mich,
da man es hätte voraussehen können.
Es gibt Täter,
bei denen
schon ganz früh sichtbar ist,
dass sie eine Disposition für z.B.
Gewalt- und Sexualverbrechen haben.
Es gibt Charaktereigenschaften,
die früh determiniert sind.
Da kann man sich fragen, ob es
sogar genetisch festgelegt ist.
Schaut man sich
Werner Ferraris Jugendzeit an,
fällt auf, dass sie
schon beinahe klischeehaft war -
verglichen
mit anderen Verbrecherkarrieren.
Er war ein klassisches Heimkind,
war früh von der Mutter
weggegeben worden.
Wie er es in den Briefen schilderte,
hatte er zu Hause
nie Liebe erfahren.
Er wurde von einem Heim ins nächste
geschickt,
wurde kleinkriminell.
Ihm hatte die Mutterliebe gefehlt,
das familiäre Umfeld.
Anerkennung.
Und ...
... Schenken von Wärme.
Das war auch ein Grund,
weshalb er die Taten beging.
Es gibt ja Zeugen, die sagen:
"Es war eine schlimme Kindheit,
deswegen kam es dazu."
Das ist so natürlich falsch.
Es gibt viele Menschen
mit schlimmer Kindheit.
Zum Glück bringen die wenigsten
deswegen Kinder um.
* Düstere Musik *
In einem Brief
beschreibt er eine Situation,
als er einmal zu Hause war
und sein Stiefvater
seinen Kopf unter Wasser drückte,
um ihn zu ertränken.
Das muss ein traumatisches Erlebnis
gewesen sein.
Das kommt immer wieder vor.
Auch in seinen Briefen ist
der Tonfall oft etwas weinerlich,
wenn er fast als Begründung angibt,
nie Liebe erfahren zu haben
und er immer
auf der Suche danach war.
Wenn jemand wehrlos schreit -
insbesondere Kinder -
dreht etwas in mir durch,
weil ich mich selber schreien höre.
Ich höre plötzlich, wie ich
um mein eigenes Leben schrie,
als mich mein Stiefvater
zu ertränken versuchte.
Ich höre mich schreien,
wie ich als Kind geschlagen wurde.
Und aus Verzweiflung darüber,
allein gelassen worden zu sein.
Es ist durchaus denkbar,
dass Bilder aus der Kindheit
und das Nahtoderlebnis
in der Verarbeitung
als wichtig eingearbeitet werden.
Ich bin skeptisch,
dass es eine Kausalität gibt,
dass es der Grund ist.
Wahrscheinlicher ist, dass es
eine nachträgliche Verknüpfung ist.
Ich erinnere mich an die ersten
Begegnungen mit Werner Ferrari.
Das muss mit neun, zehn Jahren
gewesen sein.
Da kam er in unsere Familie,
und zwar aufgrund des
Arbeitsverhältnisses meines Vaters.
Er arbeitete in der Migros.
Er hatte Werner Ferrari
als Mitfahrer.
Und so wurde er dann eingeladen.
Er ging dann
in der Familie ein und aus.
Mein Name ist Kurt Schnidrig
und ich komme ursprünglich
aus Adelboden.
Vor fast 40 Jahren
lernte ich Marco Ferrari kennen.
In meiner Kindheit.
Natürlich bin ich nervös,
aber das liegt mehr an den Lichtern,
den Kameras und den Menschen hier.
Nicht unbedingt wegen Marco Ferrari.
Er heisst ja sowohl Marco
als auch Werner.
Der eine Teil liebt Kinder,
der andere bringt sie um.
Das ist das Erstaunliche
am Fall Ferrari.
Er sagte immer, er sei Marco.
Aber gut ...
Ja, das ist ein interessanter Punkt.
Er heisst doch Marco Werner Ferrari,
nicht?
Ja.
Die Familie wusste,
woher Werner Ferrari kam,
dass er in Heimbetrieben
aufgewachsen war.
Dass er einen Vormund
und einen Beistand hatte.
Das wussten wir ...
... als Jugendliche,
aber nicht detailliert.
Meine Mutter küsste mich nie.
Sie hielt nicht einmal meine Hand
oder tröstete mich, wenn ich weinte.
Ich wurde nur hin- und hergeschoben
wie ein störendes Möbelstück,
hoffend,
dass es jemand unauffällig entsorgt.
Er ist ein schrecklicher Mörder.
Er tat Dinge,
die nicht entschuldbar sind.
Aber wenn man sieht,
was der durchmachte,
die ganze Kindheit ...
Nur schon die Kinderheime,
in denen er aufwuchs,
die Gewalt, die er erleben musste,
der ganze Scheiss,
den er durchmachte ...
Das entschuldigt es nicht,
aber wenn man
so ein scheiss Leben hat ...
* Düstere Musik *
Sein Verstand versuchte,
ihm Liebe und Geborgenheit
zu verschaffen.
Offensichtlich von Kindern,
denn die sind noch unverdorben.
Da ging es am ehesten,
bei Frauen klappte es ja nie.
Wenn ich mich richtig erinnere,
traf er die Kinder an einem Markt.
Er versuchte, sich anzunähern.
Bei den Annäherungen
schrien die Kinder und wehrten sich.
Dann kam es offensichtlich ...
... zum Tod, also sie starben,
wurden ermordet.
Bei mir
lief es nach dem gleichen Muster ab.
Ich wehrte mich einfach nicht.
Ich dachte:
"Cool, ich kann mit
dem blauen VW Käfer herumfahren!"
"Der kauft mir Süssigkeiten."
"Danke, alles gut."
Natürlich sagte ich nie,
er solle seine Zuneigung zeigen.
Als Kind
kam mir das gar nicht seltsam vor.
Wie soll ich sagen ...
Ich hatte nicht das Gefühl,
dass ich mich wehren musste.
Wir bauten eine Beziehung auf -
ich, die Familie und Marco Ferrari.
Und plötzlich verschwand er.
Kurze Zeit später
las man in der Zeitung über ihn
und ich dachte: "Okay ..."
"Shit, bin ich froh und dankbar,
dass ich noch am Leben bin."
Eigentlich ist Werner Ferrari auch
ein Produkt unserer Gesellschaft.
Man fragt sich natürlich,
wer was falsch gemacht hat.
Die Heimmaschinerie,
die Justiz
und die sozialen Einrichtungen,
durch die er alle ging ...
Die Fehler, die begangen wurden ...
Diese Überlegungen mache ich mir,
um das einordnen zu können.
* Seufzer *
Das Huhn oder das Ei?
Werner Ferrari
kam früh von zu Hause weg ...
... und kam in Heime.
Da gibt es natürlich nicht die
gleiche Zuneigung und Mutterliebe.
Man bemüht sich darum, aber es
klappt nicht auf die gleiche Art.
Im Mai 1980
wird die zwölfjährige Ruth
in diesem Waldstück in Würenlos/AG
ermordet.
Lange dachte man,
Werner Ferrari sei der Mörder.
Jetzt muss man ihn in diesem Fall
möglicherweise freisprechen.
Der Fall Ruth S. zeigt deutlich,
dass zum Zeitpunkt
von Ferraris Verhaftung
viele Menschen und auch Ermittler
einen Gedanken hatten:
Der ist für die ganze Mordserie
verantwortlich.
Darum schaute man vielleicht nicht
mehr so genau hin.
Warum tut sich die Aargauer Justiz
im Fall Würenlos
seit Jahren so schwer?
"Schweiz aktuell" fragt nach.
Gerichtspräsident Guido Näf
leitet die Untersuchungen.
Es wurden wahrscheinlich Fehler
und Unterlassungen begangen.
Das kann man im Nachhinein sagen.
Ich sprach mit Peter Holenstein,
der ein Buch über Werner Ferrari
geschrieben hatte.
"Der Unfassbare".
Wir hatten Indizien,
dass Ferrari das erste Delikt
nicht begangen hatte.
Man hatte ja alle möglichen Indizien
zusammengetragen.
Es gab viele,
die im Fall Ruth S.
gegen Werner Ferrari sprachen.
Aber wir wussten nicht alles.
Möglicherweise
auch die Polizei lange nicht.
(Winzenried) Die Ermittlungsmethoden
waren damals bedeutend kleiner
und begrenzter,
als das heute der Fall ist.
Die Mittel fehlten einfach.
Ich habe aber noch heute
den Eindruck,
dass wo der Mensch
im Mittelpunkt stand, der Polizist,
alles Mögliche getan wurde.
Peter Holenstein hatte ja
mit Eltern der Opfer zu tun -
u.a. mit Familie S.
Als Folge der Gespräche
konnte sich der Vater erinnern,
dass ihm eine Frau
zwei Fotografien gegeben hatte,
auf denen eine Familie
bei der Gartenarbeit zu sehen war.
Die Frau, die mir die Fotos brachte,
sagte etwas wie:
"Könnte er das sein?"
Irgendeine Bemerkung.
Ich fragte nicht einmal,
wer sie war oder so.
Ich war völlig abwesend.
Zu Hause
warf ich die Fotos irgendwohin.
Auch die Polizei
erhielt damals das Foto.
Sie will das heute
nicht mehr kommentieren.
Inzwischen ist klar: Die Missachtung
des Fotos war ein Fehler.
Sie können sich nicht vorstellen,
wie viele Menschen sich im Verlauf
des Verfahrens meldeten
und meinten, sie hätten eine Spur.
Sie wüssten,
dass dieses und jenes nicht so war.
Wie Verschwörungstheorien.
Peter Holenstein
kam dann zu mir und fragte,
was wir tun könnten,
um herauszufinden,
wer der Mann ist
und wo das ist.
Im Hintergrund sieht man ein Haus
mit charakteristischen
roten Fensterumrandungen.
Ich konnte das Bild dann publizieren
mit der Frage:
"Entlastet dieses Bild
Kindermörder Ferrari?"
Tatsächlich
rief am Tag der Erscheinung
um ca. 9 Uhr ein Nachbar an.
Er meinte,
das Haus stehe ganz in seiner Nähe.
Es war 1:1 das Haus.
Und er sagte nur,
er habe die Familie gekannt,
sie sei jedoch weggezogen.
Glücklicherweise rief uns am Abend
der Schwager eines Herrn R. an.
Er erzählte uns,
dass er sich an den Abend erinnere,
als bekannt wurde, dass Ruth S.
umgebracht und gefunden worden war.
Sein Schwager
habe sich sehr seltsam aufgeführt.
Er habe eine frische Bisswunde
an der Hand gehabt.
Er habe später einmal gesagt,
er habe einem Mädchen
ein Reh zeigen wollen,
habe es in Wirklichkeit
aber nur betatschen wollen.
Warum die Weiber
immer so schreien müssten.
Das wusste er alles noch.
Ich fragte ihn, ob er das
der Polizei jemals gemeldet hatte.
Er behauptete schon.
In den Unterlagen fanden wir aber
nie einen solchen Hinweis.
Für uns war es ein Hit,
dass wir jemanden gefunden hatten,
der einen engen Bezug
zu diesem Mädchen hatte.
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
Der Friedhof in Wolfhalden
heute Nachmittag.
In diesem Grab liegt ein Mann,
der am Mord von Ruth
von vor über 20 Jahren
beteiligt gewesen sein könnte.
Die Strafverfolgungsbehörden be-
harren bis heute auf Werner Ferrari
und sträuben sich,
weiter zu ermitteln.
Verantwortlicher Staatsanwalt
ist Erich Kuhn.
Gäbe es im Fall Würenlos
einen Freispruch,
könnte er weiter ermitteln lassen -
doch er tut es nicht.
Sein Grund: Gegen Tote
werde nicht ermittelt. Und:
Das Delikt ist verjährt.
Es wurde 1980 begangen,
die Verjährungsfrist für solche
Delikte ist maximal 20 Jahre.
Es gibt keine gesetzliche Grundlage,
um einen neuen Täter zu suchen.
Man darf nicht weiterforschen.
Für eine Revision
braucht es sichere Beweismittel.
Die gab es ja nicht.
Wir arbeiteten auch
mit Ferraris Anwalt zusammen.
Der Anwalt hatte die Idee,
Herrn R. zu exhumieren.
So kam es dazu,
dass das Gericht den Auftrag gab,
den Mann zu exhumieren.
Sie lassen den 1983 verstorbenen
E.R. exhumieren,
um seine Zähne mit den Bissspuren
auf Ruths Leiche zu vergleichen.
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
Mein Name ist Bernhard Knell.
In meiner Funktion als Konsiliarius
des rechtsmedizinischen Instituts
der Uni Zürich
durfte ich 2005 ein Gutachten
im Fall Werner Ferrari schreiben.
In Werner Ferraris Gebiss
gibt es zwei Auffälligkeiten:
Zum einen fehlt im Oberkiefer
rechts der zweite Prämolar,
der kleine Backenzahn.
Zum Unterkiefer
erhielt ich von Herrn Ferrari
die überzeugende Äusserung,
ein Junge habe ihm mit einer Bürste
einen Zahn ausgeschlagen.
Das waren die beiden Auffälligkeiten
in Werner Ferraris Gebiss -
im Gegensatz
zum Gebiss des Doppelgängers.
In der Bissspur war v.a.
die Unterkieferfront gut sichtbar.
Das ist klassisch,
der Unterkiefer
ist beim Beissen dynamischer.
Entsprechend konzentrierten wir uns
v.a. auf die unteren Zähne.
Dort fiel auf,
dass der untere Eckzahn rechts
um 90 Grad rotiert war.
Das ist nicht so häufig.
Dann sahen wir,
dass im Gegensatz zu Ferraris Gebiss
vier Frontzähne vorhanden waren.
Und die standen in einem Engstand.
Das waren wohl
die Hauptauffälligkeiten.
Werner Ferrari verlangt
aufgrund dieser Erkenntnisse
eine Neubeurteilung des Falls.
Am 10. April 2007
steht er deshalb
wieder vor dem Bezirksgericht Baden.
Im Revisionsprozess wird beurteilt,
ob er im Fall Ruth S. Täter ist.
Es kam ja zu einer Revision.
Da neue Beweise und Zeugenaussagen
zum Vorschein kamen,
von denen wir im ersten Prozess
nichts gewusst hatten.
Ich ging davon aus ...
... dass es bei vier Kindsmorden
keine Diskussion
über die Gefängnisdauer geben würde.
Dass lebenslänglich gesetzt ist.
Und ...
... dann spielt ein Mord
mehr oder weniger keine Rolle.
Das ist nicht ganz richtig.
Betreffend Strafmass
bringt es ihm sicher nichts.
Er wurde rechtskräftig
für fünf Morde verurteilt.
Wenn es nun vier sind,
hat es keinen Einfluss
auf das Strafmass
von lebenslangem Zuchthaus.
Es ist aber sehr wohl
von grosser Bedeutung,
ob er das fünfte Kind - das erste
dieser Serie - umbrachte oder nicht.
Auch ein rechtskräftig
verurteilter Mörder
hat das Recht
auf Unschuldsvermutung.
(TV) Zentraler Streitpunkt
im Prozess
waren zwei unterschiedliche
Gutachten zur Bisswunde am Opfer.
Am Morgen des Prozesses
war ich auf jeden Fall nervöser,
als ich das sonst bin.
Ich wusste,
dass der Staatsanwalt dagegen war,
dass das ganze Verfahren
noch einmal aufgegleist wurde.
Meines Wissens war er auch gegen
die Exhumierung des Doppelgängers.
Er meinte:
"Gegen Tote wird nicht ermittelt."
Er war überzeugt davon,
dass Werner Ferrari zu Recht
auch für diesen Fall
verurteilt worden war.
Er liess da nicht locker.
Entsprechend versuchte er immer,
mich zu erschüttern
und meine Aussagen
infrage zu stellen,
indem er die gleichen Fragen
immer wieder anders stellte.
Ich zweifelte immer daran,
dass aufgrund einer Fotografie
wissenschaftliche Aussagen
gemacht werden können.
Das ist keine solide Beweisführung.
Als Staatsanwalt hat man so
nichts Sicheres in der Hand.
Da fühlte ich mich
in meiner Wissenschaftlichkeit
ein wenig herausgefordert.
Für mich wurde meine Kompetenz
infrage gestellt.
Für mich war offensichtlich,
dass meine Zuordnung eindeutig war.
Am 11. April 2007
kommt das Gericht zum Schluss,
dass erhebliche Zweifel
an Ferraris Täterschaft bestehen.
Das Urteil:
Freispruch im Fall Ruth S.
Im Nachhinein kann gesagt werden,
dass es bezüglich Ruth S.
ein Fehlurteil war.
Im zweiten Verfahren
kamen wir auch zur Überzeugung,
dass es nicht Werner Ferrari
gewesen war.
Also mussten wir ihn freisprechen.
Ich empfand es als positiv,
dass ein Fehler der Justiz
korrigiert werden konnte.
Und noch wichtiger,
dass man der Familie von Ruth S.
die Gewissheit geben konnte,
wer für die Bissspuren
verantwortlich war
bzw. der mögliche Täter war.
Ich bin überzeugt,
dass der Freispruch
im Revisionsprozess im Fall Ruth
richtig war.
Es war zwar ein Freispruch
"im Zweifel für den Angeklagten",
aber schaut man sich
die Recherchen an -
mit der Exhumierung der Leiche
eines anderen Verdächtigen,
dem Vergleich der Gebisse -,
ist die Beweislage
für mich eigentlich klar.
Er ist nicht der Mörder von Ruth S.
Ausserdem bestritt er diese Tat
von Anfang an.
(Reporter)
Sind Sie zufrieden mit dem Urteil?
Nein.
-Warum nicht?
(TV) Ferrari ist nicht zufrieden,
weil er darauf beharrt,
in allen Fällen unschuldig zu sein,
und da sich am Urteil "Zuchthaus
lebenslänglich" nichts geändert hat.
Das Strafmass von Werner Ferrari
ist ja lebenslängliches Zuchthaus.
Lebenslänglich
heisst lebenslänglich.
Es ist ganz klar:
Die Öffentlichkeit muss
vor so schweren Straftätern
geschützt werden.
Selbst wenn das dazu führt,
dass ein Mensch ein Leben lang
nie wieder freigelassen wird.
Ferrari hatte einen grossen Einfluss
auf das
gesellschaftspolitische Klima.
Das zeigt sich daran,
dass in der Bevölkerung
ein Ruf nach Strafverschärfung
hochkam.
Die Politik reagierte.
Schliesslich
kam es zu neuen Gesetzen.
Diese bewirkten bei
schweren Delikten härtere Strafen.
Wie viele Morde Werner Ferrari
beging, weiss nur er selber.
Wie ich ihn einschätze,
hat er auch das verdrängt.
Oder er behält es für sich.
Mit den Opfern und v.a.
den Angehörigen fühlte ich mit.
Auch mit Ferraris, denn Angehörige
von Tätern sind ja auch Opfer.
Aber mit ihm - nein.
Dieser Mann darf nicht freigelassen
werden, das ist das Wichtigste.
Das beschäftigt mich jeden Tag.
Nicht nur mich,
auch meine Tochter und meinen Sohn.
Alle leiden mit.
Das ist einfach so.
Wir feiern ihren Geburtstag
jedes Jahr -
weil wir uns sagen,
dass sie das so gewollt hätte.
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
puretype gmbh - 2022